wisst ja dass ich seit 5 Jahren einfach
nicht mehr diese
schildrüsenunterfunktionssymptome habe
wie Müdigkeit Trägheit man fühlt sich
gar nicht mehr fit ein ist ständig kalt
man braucht mittagstaft das habe ich ja
seit 5 Jahren nicht mehr weil ich eben
das Schwarzkümmelöl jeden Tag einnehme
aber was viele nicht wissen ist dass es
noch einen anderen schönen zeiteffekt
hat ihr bekommt dadurch nämlich mega
schöne dicke glänzende Haare ihr bekommt
dadurch bessere Haut es kann
entzündungshemd wirken es hat es enthält
sogar Biotin viele nehmen auch
Biotintabletten das habt ihr hier alles
drin für den schönheitsaspekt also hat
wirklich einen schönen zeiteffekt starke
Fingernägel alles eigentlich und viele
haben mir auch geschrieben die
neurodemitis haben die nehmen aber oft
dann auch meine Seife noch dazu und das
Balsam aber geben sich auch das
Schwarzkümmelöl einfach mitten auf die
Haut oder auch auf die Kopfhaut weil da
haben ja auch viele Schwierigkeiten und
das könnt ihr natürlich auch machen das
wissen nämlich die meisten gar nicht